I went through a divorce and then I
started dating after that and it's like
well if going out on a date with a guy
makes me a [ __ ]
then that's just what I'm gonna be I
don't think going out on a date made you
a [ __ ] but having sex with different men
makes you makes you a [ __ ] well what
does it make you if you have sex with
different women a [ __ ] maker
my younger sister used to be three years
younger than me now she's 23 years
younger there's not a single solitary
Biden man that is younger than any Biden
woman yeah Finance
I'm not even going to look at the screen
that's the correct answer
[Applause]
[Music]
It Isn't
So I give this whole speech like you
gotta get mad you got to bring them in
you got to like buy the tickets like I
got I went to Indiana Jones and jaws and
every movie that Steven Spielberg's ever
made and by the way he's never made a
movie with a female lead
sorry Stephen
I don't mean to call your ass out but
it's true
The Color Purple thank you okay I'm
wrong
[Music]
um
it's very rare that you find something
like this that you really like uh and
and that's so awesome and I and I thank
you all for doing
so so so I I was as just about as
awkward as you thought it was going to
be bye so I went
and all the girls just made it I see
them just move
I just let God take it from there
the Red Sea mommy academics
[ __ ] said this this [ __ ] spread like
the rest here nothing I just saw God and
God said just you know prepared for
impact
honestly I think we should just trust
our president in every decision that he
makes and we should just support that
you know and um
now with that said I saw you in London
talking a couple weeks ago on TV and you
seemed a lot more excited about it than
you do right now are you just exhausted
oh uh no I mean I'm still very excited
I'm you know the premier was last night
it was an emotional it was an emotional
night it felt like the end of an era but
I'm not any less excited than I was a
couple of weeks ago maybe add a bit more
energy it's the morning
you do seem a bit a bit irritated
perhaps it's just us
no no I think it's just you I think it
probably is um
we figured as much we'll let you go then
how about that I'll let you go take a
little nap maybe get a Red Bull how
about that
Cara Delevingne thank you so much
foreign
she's also in that Taylor Swift video
Bad Blood everybody probably recognizes
her from that as well just reach out and
see it won't you it's a good movie
that's so funny let's tune in and see
what you oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
Anastasia and 50 Shades of Gray has done
so well at the box office feels like
everybody has seen it have you no no
what do you yeah what do you do you have
to stay in there you don't want to see
it maybe one day I don't think I can
yeah I think it would be strange no I
don't think so I think it's fine I think
that one day you can see it yeah I think
so and I'll just tell you until you see
it she's really good and yeah there's
there are those scenes but she's also
just a really well she's a really good
actress I don't need to see that to know
how good she is all right you don't have
to see it
you know Pythagoras's Theorem to the
nearest five decimal places do you
what's your favorite color do you do you
know them yeah
there's the first four digits
in the bathroom for five minutes are you
serious
I have never taken
such a fast piss
in my whole life
thank you everybody
[Applause]
you do some pretty good animal
impersonations
best yourself everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
and Hathaway good morning nice to see
you seen a lot of you lately sorry about
that I I'd be happy to stay home but the
film let's just get it out of the way
you had a little wardrobe malfunction
the other night what's the lesson
learned from something like that other
than that you keep smiling which you
always do
well
it was obviously an unfortunate incident
um I think
it kind of made me sad uh on two
accounts one was that I was very sad
that we live in an age when someone
takes a picture of another person in a
vulnerable moment and rather than delete
it and do the decent thing sells it and
I'm sorry that we live in a culture that
commodifies sexuality of unwilling
participants which brings us back to Les
Mis because that's what my character is
she is someone who is forced to sell sex
to benefit her child because she has
nothing and there's no social safety net
and I yeah so um so let's so let's get
back to creative terms of a question I
have ever heard and I'm gonna take it at
that that's fine if you get any
questionable calls please tell us by
going to report fraud report fraud
Dot ftc.gov
[Music]
everybody's definitely looking at me now
[Music]
[Music]
I swear to God I don't punch you in your
face so do it don't look at me do it
already
stop okay stop you too okay you said
it's Ellie's top it's beautiful yeah it
is and it's ombre it's like ombre teal
it gets lighter to the bottom and then I
have purple shoes on because why not I
just wanted to show the legs because as
I was telling you ahead of time you're
going to walk home with more than maybe
just a trophy tonight I think lots of
men I'm not gonna walk home with any men
tonight I'm gonna I'm gonna go hang out
with my friends and then I go home to
the cats no men allowed men get me in
trouble I don't get tree voting it feels
like a real turning point in the Trump
candidacy
he gonna win
and a really smart way um
excuse me
my dad just blew a little frog out of
there
tell me or is it true you're wandering
the streets you need a date to the party
what's up no no no I'm I'm doing just
fine uh I just uh you know there's no
meaning to any of this so I I wanted to
find the most meaningless thing that I
could come to and join and uh and uh and
here I am
there's something you gotta admit it's
completely meaningless
they say they're celebrating icons
inside reading icons boy that is just
the absolute lowest aiming you know
possibility that we could come up with
it's like icons what do you do you
believe in icons I don't believe in
personalities I don't believe that you
exist but there is a wonderful fragrance
in the air
you don't believe certain icons have the
power to make change to think
differently to be bold to inspire others
Artistry you're one of them on the Good
Foot
yeah you shut her down now